it's time to babble the [ __ ] on
this Hollywood babble-on with your hosts
Kevin Smith and Ralph Garman
[Applause]
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
you guys are adorable man it is Saturday
night in San Juan Capistrano man we all
know that you swallow
so let's babble the [ __ ] on I'm Kevin
Smith
and my name is Ralph Garman
well aren't you nice it's a little warm
in the room folks if you're listening to
the show you hear the sound of a
thousand whirring fans pointed at the
fattest man in the room and that'd be me
so you'll hear a lot of this as I fan
myself it's like I'm in a Tyler Perry
movie hallelujah Oh totally it's awesome
for me to be back to the coach-house you
have you been here before never been
here my first time I came here with
you'll never forget your first time yeah
this place I told Ralph like I came here
to play Jay and Silent Bob get old too
Jason Mewes and I went back to Ralph oh
no I talked about this place like it was
a box of Playboy's that I found in the
woods man I said you got to come to the
coach-house cool we have to go back I
was and also I told him I was just like
Ralph's in this movie Ted which made a
gazillion dollar
I'm pretty sure was my four minutes that
made it made it the smash hit made all
the difference do but you play who's
father I play Mark Wahlberg's father
okay so I was telling my sick dude I
played the coach-house and backstage at
the coach ass man they got signed
photographs up and down this
[ __ ] for people who've played
here and I asked cats at one point I was
like who comes to play at the Coach
House like people on their way up and
people under way back and then wait a
minute which one are we I don't know I
hesitate to ask but I saw this picture
in the back and it's a signed picture of
Marky Mark man from literally from his
like feel it feel it days do they have
the sideways cap on oh Jesus they're
Jessica bounce a quarter off his pecs
and [ __ ] looking very sexy did you
defile that picture no he's not my type
man we know you're tight alexander
skarsgård that's your type run
i watched an episode of True Blood the
other day man where if you look really
closely in a watch shot it could see his
dick and I had blu-ray so I paused that
[ __ ] was like righteous righteous and my
wife was like wow I was like you watch
this this is your punishment for not
being him he is a pretty man if you take
care of yourself is that punishment for
her a reward yeah so you're getting off
life I was feeling pretty rectal tonight
Kevin I don't want you to look over
there but there is a guy next to you
making obscene gestures on stage
don't look don't look don't look
security
[ __ ] you I found a new partner
we got a dude here who's signing for
some folks in the crowd who can't hear
so if if you hear somebody if you hear
this at one point that's the sign
language dude passing out yeah from the
overwork we're doing and the amount of
new terms he has to figure out how to I
don't envy him yeah let's test it out
rectal fist-fucking
[Applause]
[ __ ] I could have done that fair enough
alright let's see if we can go a little
more subtle how about how about this one
give that penis a sandwich
[Music]
don't like it I'm not even SAT mom's
gonna do that
a lot of times I get happy during the
show and I described myself as being
enthusiastic I say Skeet Skeet Skeet
[Applause]
and international dude you could just
walk up to deaf people and be like Skeet
Skeet Skeet and they'll know exactly
what you mean they'll call for a cop but
they'll know exactly what you mean I
think you just did confetti
this is skeet skeet skeet this is
confetti
it's gotta go this way I can't go out
now I don't think so cuz then you get to
do this sign
speak for yourself dude it's my own come
so I'm like this I want to use these
start wiping off right now they calls me
pac-man
they calls me pac-man this sign language
I used to think oh it's so mysterious
who could do it
pac-man is literally Wacka Wacka Wacka
Wacka Eggman I know half the language
already yeah
sign language things ask a mime
well we have some hearing-impaired
people here tonight because the Deaf are
our biggest audience for our podcast
they love it they can't get enough of it
they just sit there staring at their
iPhones these guys just like I don't get
it
somebody likes them welcome to Hollywood
babble-on
right here in San Juan Capistrano let's
get started with the show by doing a
segment we like to give special thank
yous and shout us the people who came
particularly long distances or
celebrating special occasions it's a
segment known as the shout outs its
shout out Kevin and brown so get your
[ __ ] out
[Music]
cactus they're not blind they're deaf
Kevin they saw you swallowing the
microphone he doesn't need to do that I
got a shitty with the mid-performance as
you [ __ ] do this
alright let's this first one is a
callback from last week's show so if
you're listening at home stop and go
back and listen to last week's show and
then come back to this one you remember
a saito and CC yes yes the Japanese guy
with the black girlfriend who said it's
gonna be our show last week yeah yeah it
turns out he meant it was coming this
week okay yeah I guess the tsunami
washed away was it thank you
oh wow two tsunamis where's sato and
CeCe why wait yeah he did both he
spelled it out and he did waves on that
one watch - tsunami hold on Hawaii
five-o I just want to make sure it
wasn't the same like
Sato and CeCe where are you guys make
some noise way back there how are you
welcome thanks for coming night he said
I first want to apologize for last
week's shout out I forgot to mention
that we were coming tonight I sent the
email on Sunday in Japan so I assumed it
would get there after the Saturday show
don't don't start with your [ __ ]
time-travel okay I don't seriously mean
he could wind up in bed with your mother
that's right and Calvin Klein well to my
surprise I heard the new episode and I
heard Ralph say [ __ ] them for not
showing up I did that was me
I was screaming as loud as I could in
Japan but I guess you guys couldn't hear
me that's because you were screaming on
a Sunday yeah we were originally gonna
see you guys at the Lovitz in LA but
after finding out the show was in San
Juan Capistrano we cancelled our hotel
reservations got a rental car decided to
join the fun here forgive us our mistake
from last week give us a holler come on
man we came all the way from Japan where
tsunamis and radiation are ready to kill
us around every corner all right well
let it slide this time welcome to
America diplomatic immunity oh that's
the wrong once again the South Africa
has nothing to do with Japan you sure
positive let me make you feel at home oh
and mine didn't make sense
austan Jordan are you here Austin Jordan
how are you Austin Austin's here with
his mom Suzy his dad Brad and his
brother Justin I thought you were
[ __ ] making fun of them but that's
what it says in the letter says mom Suzy
dad Brad brother Justin awesome they
brought their whole [ __ ] family to a
show we're doing but [ __ ] jokes here
[Applause]
that guy is good every sign you imagine
man it's that simple
I graduated from college in May have
been brainstorming for weeks on the
perfect way to thank my parents for the
continuous love and support well this
would be the way absolutely nothing like
an evening full of anal sex jokes to
show mom and dad how much you care a
Hallmark card actually they're
questioning your taste and they're also
like what the [ __ ] did you do with all
the money we gave you funny you should
bring that up Kevin because he says
they're top-notch parents my best
friends and I really appreciate
everything they do for me I'd like to
let them know that I will someday repay
them for financing me all the way
through college but don't count on it
though Austin as what'd you get your
degree in Austin media arts mom and dad
you're not getting paid back
mom and dad for the record Media Arts is
codeword for YouTube in your best Sean
Connery could you explain to them that
they are the bee's knees you want me to
tell them never bee's knees what the
[ __ ] does that mean I don't even know
beach hat knees well listen all that
money you spent on college mom and dad
it's flushed right down the [ __ ]
toilet a degree in media arts means in
about two weeks he'll be blowing guys
for beer money behind the dumpster at
your local Shakey's try the bunch of
lunch
[Applause]
[ __ ] throw a spoonful of hope on that
would you man that was dark I'm sure
he'll do well mom and dad behind the
Shakey's are Eileen and Josh here Eileen
and Josh they're too drunk to speak but
it can still slap their flippers
together God love them my boyfriend Josh
and I will be at your show tonight it's
our first live show but my boyfriend
listens to you guys all the time I
started listening recently and [ __ ] you
guys are funny thank you it's so weird
it's like it's a discovery like wow you
guys are actually funny like when people
come up to me to talk about Jersey girl
like I saw Jersey girl wasn't that bad
don't believe the hype yeah this
weekend's our first year anniversary and
I think it's about time Josh gives up
his rusty wagon wheel to me Eileen
writes pick that [ __ ] Kevin can
you please let him know it's not that
bad have you given up your wagon wheel
No
it depends how do you feel about it
we'll talk about it after the show I
gave it up once gave it up to a finger
to a hairbrush as well I preferred the
finger which end of the hairbrush that
might have been the problem you got to
put it handle first it's true man it was
a little pokey like Loki it was it was
the ultimate Loki pokey pokey pokies
Nick changed me from a [ __ ] hero to a
villain as well your eyes got all black
Brian and Jen are you here Brian and Jen
from needles California wait man there's
some sort of feud between San Juan
Capistrano and needles there is like the
Sharks and the Jets yes
very New York New Jersey like [ __ ]
needles have no idea
Brian writes we're here from needles
California I got my first kidney stone a
few days ago and I'm hoping it will pass
by the time the show is over if not I'll
be the one moaning in pain I think it
just passed Brian have you have you
passed it yet
not yet
the other picture of beer for Brian
please
we'll get that [ __ ] out it's Jens
first time hearing the show could you
please tell her what to expect in the
voice of tv's batman Adam West thank you
Brian
well Jen here's what you can expect from
this evening
your boyfriend moaning in pain followed
by a small projectile flying across the
room quickly robin the bat-shield
holy kidney stones how about Steve and
Ron Durst even Ron dare what right up
front
hey so close secure Ralph and keV I am I
am Steve the pool man
oh you're Steve the pool man because we
were all wondering who is Steve the pool
man my wife said she [ __ ] Steve the
pool man it's a sore subject I'll be
there Saturday with my friend Rhonda who
is 20 years younger than me well now
you're just bragging Steve the pool man
I met her when her ex dropped her in the
two kids off at Grandma's house to live
I clean grandma's pool yeah
I'm tick about pound pound press one you
think like there's no more rom-coms to
make man this is excellent this is like
[ __ ] The Bad News Bears if it all
worked out for Walter Matthau yeah but
that's like every porn I've ever seen
the pool guy always gets um and
apparently Steve the pool man got
somebody 20 years younger than him
keep reading yeah my birthday is August
the 9th it'd be great if I could hear
happy birthday from out Pacino and could
I'll also tell Ronda she has a great ass
oh I gotta tell you Steve the pool man
Wow well I guess you cleaned her skimmer
huh Steve yeah smells like chlorine
[Applause]
no wait that smells something else
don't say Steve don't be in the pool
Steve don't pee in the pool Ronda oh you
got a great ass Oh Steve I think it's
all over for you oh wow time to pack up
the kids at Grandma's Steve also
mentions he's got a big audition
tomorrow for The Voice he's gonna
edition for The Voice tomorrow well best
of luck Steve Congrats man since I'm
getting a late start in my career
because unlike Kevin who's still able to
function on pot I just wanted to play
video games and clean the pool so you're
gonna go audition and you just stand
there sing for him you want to rock a
little [ __ ] give him the mic man let's
hear it
ladies gentlemen the song stylings of
Steve the pool man Roget oh [ __ ] I mean
shoot when I'm with you I feel a
thousand different feelings a cover of
chills all over my body
[Music]
[Applause]
he's [ __ ] getting so late tonight
yeah well done sir
Balu not seriously give up the ass
tonight he could have gone any way could
have gone with any song he chose to
serenade you ma'am Yeah right yeah that
totally gay judge he is sweet we can
tell yeah you know what else is sweet
[Music]
you romantic bastard you Zack here
tonight Zack you in the house
Zack here by yourself Zack anybody over
there where where Zack this is like like
at the end of Spartacus man I am Zack
well whichever one of you is Zack you're
here alone because you had a girlfriend
you were going to bring here of the past
two and a half years but you broke up a
few months ago
Zack writes the last time here alone
like a giant loser no you're not because
there's another guy named Zach who's
also alone you guys should get together
I would love it if Kevin Smith could do
Tom Hardy as bane saying give that penis
a sandwich give thought to decide which
[Applause]
[Music]
[Applause]
well you never know what you could do
until you try right hey go home wake my
wife up like that nothing sexier than
Bing give this B this is bad wood she
grabs my dick she's like I pull this off
it won't be painful I was like for you
wouldn't that movie awesome man did you
see the Dark Knight I did see it did say
it yeah we didn't talk about it man what
we're gonna do a whole nother podcast
did you I liked it enough but you got
submission you got some problems with it
autopilot what else that was a big one
the beginning to [ __ ] eight years
eight years off what a lazy [ __ ]
Batman yeah my knee hurts like crime for
a handle itself I'm good and the beard
man yeah the beard just says you've
given up beard just says you got many
Chin's more Chin's than a Chinese phone
book I ought to know any retires because
his girlfriend got killed by the Joker
basically but but he saw his mom and dad
gunned down in front of him right that
spurred him on to a life of fighting
crime the girlfriend gets axes like I'm
just not feeling it anymore yeah I'm
gonna I'm gonna play with my bow and
arrow in my bedroom unless crime comes
actually to my house and then I'll be
interested again and then what and then
just like the other [ __ ] big hero
movie of the summer it ends with a
billionaire flying a nuclear weapon away
from a city
yes Avengers and Dark Knight Rises into
the exact same way kind of I would have
proving once again Ralph that the
ultimate super weapon is money
I would have given anything I own if at
one point during that sequence
Christian Bale said some days you just
can't get rid of a bomb I need a bat
lozenge what's wrong with your voice I'm
gonna have to remove what we go for
no wonder I could take this city so
easily so easy to slip into scooby-doo
when you're doing Christian Bale irori
vein-like zoic Scoob I would have gotten
away with it one for you meddling kids
[Applause]
how about Shoni Jules and Morgan are you
guys here you [ __ ] did you send me a
2-page [ __ ] email and you're not here
fuck'em is right what a shock Ralph's
got stood up by a girl hey what the yeah
should we do it just of generic Bowie
because I know people love to see you
dance like I like a porn star
yeah we do David Bowie's saying [ __ ] you
to show knee for not showing up tonight
how about that show me show me
I'm really pissed
so I say [ __ ] you should I just don't
like
[Applause]
[Music]
I wish you had shown well we're having
fun without you that's not coming out I
went like sideways like a salad shooter
we also get emails from all around the
world featuring Kevin's reactions hi
guys
Matt here from Canberra Australia
diplomatic immunity
nope still not welcome after hearing
Ralph's Aaron Neville last week and
being instantly transported to 1990 I
was wondering a Ralph could kindly
oblige us all with Aaron Neville singing
Edelweiss
thanks for the labs and for Kevin's
faultless impersonation of Marc Jacko
Jackson he loves you Jacko oh well I'm
gonna energize you really yeah he likes
that of everything I've done on the show
he's like you've been okay with that yes
alright Aaron Neville singing thanks
[Music]
you finish shut up again Big Finish
bless my homeland
[Applause]
[Music]
Ricky Nelson that song man like that
sounds [ __ ] good
I would listen to that in my car just
weep while driving this next email is
from BC Canada this is from Sarah she
says I've been slowly turning all my
friends into fellow Babylonians so first
of which was my friend Gemma
unfortunately Gemma is now moving and we
were having a going-away party for her a
group of us are gonna get together and
listen to HBO and play the drinking game
she wanted to shout out Sarah from BC
Canada well if they're playing the
drinking game while they're listening to
us let's give him something really to
drink about I also don't know if I buy
this story man bunch of girls sitting
around listening to Hollywood babble-on
naked he's in hockey jerseys cuz they're
in town oh [ __ ] I'm sorry I gotta go
clean up and then they get drunk while
they're playing the Babylon drinking
game and then the pillow fight starts
what kind of hockey sweaters we talking
about old school with the drawstring or
kind of a synchro mesh drawstring
definitely drawstring yeah do the voices
of the girls know Jesus you're creepy
Amy writes from Ireland my awesome
brother Dave introduced me to Hollywood
babble-on can you please give my brother
a shout-out as John Travolta and tell
him he's so weird for making me sit in
his car and listen to details about
rusty wagon wheels I guess it would be
weird doing with your brother that is
kind of strange like you sit here listen
to this these guys talk about [ __ ] a
lot yeah the awkward conversations that
follow it's so weird
listen with your sister about anal
what where it's so weird let's [ __ ]
and lastly Brandon from Halifax Nova
Scotia writes in I may be going to hell
for suggesting this but I was hoping you
could try out post-stroke Dick Clark as
the creepy clown see you didn't like it
at first but then the idea grew on you
I'm gonna just show you what hell looks
like Ralph the layers of hell and Ron
executive write the child petr ass right
Dick Clark Impressionists wow you sure
you want to go for this well Brandon
asked and he said I'm not sure if this
will work but it will succeed in making
everyone uncomfortable oh here we go
it's creepy clown time Kevin creepy
clowns on creepy clown time
[Music]
[Music]
all right it's creepy clown time all
right
post-stroke Dick Clark Oh as the creepy
clown putting on his makeup should we
count down to it
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
Ryan
there we go Happy New Year everybody
every week we take a look at the lives
of some folks who have left us here in
show business and they deserve a final
send-off it's a segment we call
Tinseltown stiffs and now another
edition of
[Music]
they will be missed it is a a wide and
varied group this week that we say
goodbye to starting with Marvin Hamlisch
who was a legendary film composer now
that he also wrote for Broadway he wrote
that movie The Musical rather a chorus
line he did legendary screenplay scores
for about 40 different film scores he
did he started off his career though
writing pop songs one was a hit for 60s
pop star Lesley gore you may know this
song if you watch The Simpsons on a
regular basis
it's called sunshine lollipops and
rainbows love that you kept dancing
after it was okay no because I wanted
more he liked it that much
he was Annie got for those of you who
watched 30 rock you know what that is he
won an Emmy and a Golden Globe an Oscar
and a Tony he was one of the few people
who won every major wart in his career
that's what he got means yeah it was
like wow those people that [ __ ] Eagles
or something I was like oh I got a
[ __ ] Cigna caption for everything
three Oscars four Emmys a Tony three
Golden Globes he won an Oscar for his
adaptation of Scott Joplin's music for
the movie the sting if I've ever seen
the sting this theme is probably very
familiar to you
gotta remake that movie you me all the
more reason to remake this thing you and
me generally you know just makes you
feel like walking down the street Marvin
Hamlisch will be missed
Judith Crist what's the matter
is that Megan yeah she brought me a
drink I'd love her people were like
hooting her man well she's an attractive
young lady she just got married sorry
fella she's taken yeah yeah I got a
little protective I was like who [ __ ] it
who did I think it was a sign language
guy which was pretty impressive if you
think about it yeah he did this so hard
sound actually came out
Judith Chris the film critic passed away
at the age of 90 this week she was the
first critic who started really with the
insults in reviews she kind of that was
her trademark Oh like she didn't like
did you ever review any year films good
I don't know if she did or not but she
didn't like some classics like something
like it hot Billy Wilder's something
like a hot classic film she said it was
perverse and had too many homosexual in
jokes well she wouldn't like to your
movies if that's the case that's the
review she gave her something like it
hot yes pervert she didn't like it
didn't like it Billy Wilder said asking
her to review a movie was like asking
the Boston Strangler to massage your
neck
but she did champion Steven Spielberg
early in his career and Woody Allen as
well so she had a good side too she
passed away at the age of 90 this week
really listened bitter wisdom to people
live to be very old that's why I'm gonna
live forever
mean an empty cherry or some day going
khloe kardashian and harry [ __ ] cheated
why knowledge the fact that I'm no
longer on the show at that point well
you ever once a while look over and be
like I outlived him because my head was
strong the dark side is strong with me
we're talking about Spielberg Carlo
Rambaldi passed away this week at 86
years old he is a special effects genius
his claim to fame really was the fact
that he invented ET that was all him et
the puppet that he created for the movie
could do a hundred and fifty separate
moves wrinkle its nose for its brow
extend its neck get an erect penis there
was everything everything he wanted him
to do I remember from the cut scene man
I'll be right here
Hill where should my mouth be et turn on
your [ __ ] light let it shine all over
the world and my face and neck tits
did alien eat the monster in alien that
was his to one the alien monster he did
that as well yeah what was last time you
watch TT it's been a long time wow it
looks literally it literally looks like
what it is like a puppet a hundred
different moves to it I'm not saying
like replace it with CG but it's just
when you look at it now you're like man
we settled for four puppetry back in the
days no kid would lose magical that was
magical only was a magical puppet you
know just like Alf
in the age of C GE T and alpha right
next to one another is like huh [ __ ] he
also did kink I'm in 1976 King Kong that
was him
and they built a massive King Kong 445
feet tall nobody [ __ ] does that movie
they're never like let's just build it
the real size because there are people
sensible enough to be like it won't work
that's what happens they built it and it
wouldn't work they used it in very few
shots they used it for the shot at the
end where he's falling off the buildings
they laid him down said look it's been
impressive 45 feet tall well long really
he's laying down but Pete a tribute to
you remember the show alias JJ Abrams
yeah with Jennifer Garner remember the
Rambaldi devices they kept firing on the
show they were named after Carlo
Rambaldi who created ET free you can
take that home share it with your
friends that's that's on me that one go
home wake up your wife with that piece
of information watch how quickly you get
blown
and lastly director Mel Stewart passed
away this week at the age of 83
he was an award-winning documentary what
documentary filmmaker documentary in the
60s and he wasn't much of a fiction
director but his daughter Madeleine told
him her favorite book needed to be made
into a movie in that book was Charlie in
the Chocolate Factory
and he made Willy Wonka and the
Chocolate Factory back in 1971 he was
the director of that film it's a great
film yes one of my favorites still to
this day I guess it makes sense man no
I'm now hearing that he didn't make a
bunch of stuff he was a documentary and
that movie had a different feel to it
especially for a kid's moon i know it's
based on the source material is also a
little off-center but that movie now
that I think about I go yeah I guess
that would make kind of sense I watched
it the other day I watch it every couple
of months I just loved that film there's
a sequence where they're in the boat
remember and they're going through that
dark tunnel and if you watch the footage
that's being projected on the walls
behind them there's a scene where like a
chicken gets its head cut off with a
hatchet like this is a kids movie
there's a little audio from that
sequence this is this is Gene Wilder
while they're in the boat and they're
rowing through the the tunnel if you
ever seen the film just losing his
[ __ ] [ __ ] and I just remember being
terrified as a child and thinking Mel
Stuart's of just a sick [ __ ] the
director of that film hears low audio
not a speck of light is showing so the
danger must be growing are the fires of
hell of glowing
is the grisly reaper mowing yes
[Music]
roars keep on rowing and they're
certainly not showing
[Music]
I just [ __ ] my pants it's missing one
more and the Opus they are blowing Mel
Stuart said about his film he wanted it
to be dark I'm not talking down to
children giving them squirrels with
funny faces and stuff like that
he said well you didn't Mel you gave us
nightmares thank you so much thank you
for so much for that I appreciate it you
get nothing good day sir I didn't like
that test he had to see if he can he's
gonna run a [ __ ] factories gig over
some kid who like cracks under pressure
if he's like good day sure I think it
was like please mr. well suck your dick
he don't want to give it to that kid he
wants to give it to the kid who's like
you know what [ __ ] you
man me and Grandpa are leaving going
final mr. slugworth no he gave back the
everlasting gods Gobstopper didn't take
it with them oh that was the final straw
where will he says come back here
Charlie unzip my pants we can take a
sunrise sprinkle it with goo mashup have
a bite of my scrumdiddlyumptious bar
charlie while we're talking about Willy
Wonka it's only appropriate because this
week Willy Wonka is featured in a
segment we like to call [ __ ] that should
not be
[Music]
here's some [ __ ] that should this week's
movie is Willy Wonka and the Chocolate
Factory and usually when we do this
segment we show you some some video
footage but this actually is from the
film the story itself is the [ __ ] that
should not be and you'll understand why
in a minute you may remember the famous
sequence in the film where Willy Wonka
is bragging about as many inventions and
one of which is wallpaper for children's
nurseries that is lickable it's lickable
wallpaper
the oranges taste like oranges the
pineapples taste like pineapples it's a
revolution in candy that you can have
lickable wallpaper Feliz you don't
remember here's here's the sequence I'm
talking about pastic it tastes so real
try some more the strawberries taste
like strawberries the snozzberries taste
like snozzberries snozzberry we are the
music makers and we are the dreamers of
dreams I would have punched Veruca right
in the snatch snozzberries is a word we
all learned from that film and carried
it with us and we laughed because it
didn't really mean anything it was an
adorable little phrase snozzberries well
thank God for cracked.com because they
did a story on this recently about what
snozzberries according to the writer
Roald Dahl actually meant he used the
phrase snozberries in Wonka and then
years later he wrote an adult novel
called my uncle Oswald
uncle Oswald was the greatest fornicator
of all time it says in the book and he
comes up with this great idea he's gonna
get his lovely female accomplice Yasmine
how come Lee to seduce the richest most
powerful men in the world collect their
sperm in a condom and then sell it to
women who want to have smart rich famous
children it sounds just like Willy Wonka
& the Chocolate
sir you get no come with Willy wanker in
the semen Factory that's what that
sounds like so in the sequence in the
book Yasmine how come Lee is talking
about her experience with George Bernard
Shaw how she got his sperm and here let
me read to you from the book
how did you manage to roll the old
rubbery thing on him well there's only
one way when they get violent Yasmine
said I grabbed hold of his snozzberry
and hung on to it like grim death and
gave it a twist or two to make him hold
still now we know what roald dahl meant
by snozberries snozzberries according to
roll is another word for the dink the
[ __ ] the penis that's why the little
girl was like snozzberry what's a
snozzberry he was making them lick dick
flavored wallpaper no try the
snozzberries lick the snozzberries sick
twisted [ __ ] roll well what a mad
genius it's like bananas strawberries
oranges [ __ ] yes so now we know what
snozzberries are everybody and you'll
never see that film and look at it the
same way again I promise you it's time
to take a look at the week's headlines
in showbiz news HBO headlines
[Music]
it's going down and out like a
snozzberry now we know what that is the
the story of the week for me by far are
the adventures of Randy Travis I don't
know I've been following this story or
not
Tuesday night no we don't have photos
this evening but I saw a picture you see
the mug shot holy [ __ ] yes those you
don't know Randy Travis was a huge
country star I guess in the 80s is when
he had most of his hits he I think we
all know the song now I think we're all
all the way he was sound as long as old
man sins are bound whether just as long
as the women sit and talk about old man
if you wonder how long I'll be faithful
who then listen to how the song ends
Ralph oh I'm gonna love you forever and
ever
[Applause]
hey I'll do the amen [ __ ] you guys well
done boat well well done that's Randy
Travis's big hit Tuesday night the
Grayson County Sheriff's Office in Texas
got a phone call there's a man lying by
his car in the roadway oh yeah I forgot
to mention he's naked
turns out Randy Travis showed up naked
to a convenience store I wanted to buy
some cigarettes as you do right
I have to give it to the the wherewithal
of the clerk behind the counter who said
sure how you gonna pay for him though
was his actual response man's got no
pockets you don't want to know where he
keeps his loose change I'll tell you
that much it's like a slot machine he's
[ __ ] out quarters Randy got upset
hop behind the wheel of his 1998 Trans
Am of course it was if it had the
[ __ ] Confederate flag on the roof it
to be perfect what the [ __ ] was bad that
was his word I always have those cheesy
air horns just like he got one of them
western horns this sounded like [ __ ]
burgess Meredith penguin he crashed his
car to some construction barricades the
troopers showed up he was outside the
car naked they put him in a squad car
and he threatened to shoot and kill
anyone who was trying to arrest him holy
[ __ ] yeah ah the troopers love that oh
that's their favorite answer i watch
cops a lot they dig that especially from
naked guys they let you get away with
that anymore like there was a time in
the seventies you'd be like oh he just
drunk he'll sleep it off but when you
[ __ ] threaten a cop's life man do
they go like even if you're naked we're
gonna take that seriously and hold it
against you we're gonna hold it against
them cuz he's naked you want to keep him
at arm's length yeah they do take that
seriously somebody punch in his dick let
me hear that man alright I'm a punch
[ __ ] his dick ready go
[Applause]
sounds pretty hot man hold on let me get
him three hits ready here we go
[Applause]
he's shot all over me it's one too many
Randy got charged with DUI and a felony
count of redneck er II didn't even know
that had a felony amanda Bynes is also a
hot drunk mess she's that little girl
from Nickelodeon she was so cute
Amanda manda manda manda manda manda
manda show I used to watch that was my
kid
yeah she was talented man she was like
it was like a sketch comedy show and she
played a bunch of different characters
not just a girl now she's playing drunk
driver a much easier ran into a woman in
the Toyota Corolla last week and her BMW
hopped out of a car and said the damage
isn't too bad and tried to push the
Corollas bumper back on with her hands
that is so a [ __ ] drunk move by the
way that's like no it's good she was
good as new
no I'm the fouth stoner move to that is
just like that's my stuff
that's harshing my buzz you want to go
get a sandwich
the woman said let's exchange insurance
information Amanda said no hopped in her
car and drove off police would like to
have a conversation with her they want
to ask her why she wasn't naked like
Randy Travis was more drunk driving News
Joe Simpson the creepy manager of
Jessica Simpson who at one time talked
about how beautiful his daughter's
breasts were yeah that's a good that's a
good interview you're gonna read that
some time he was pulled over here in Los
not here in Los Angeles up in Los
Angeles with a 0.12 blood-alcohol level
he was having margaritas at a Mexican
restaurant with his daughter and he kept
trying to get her drunk but she wasn't
she kept saying no so he kept drinking
last week we're talking about some
people who had come out in favor of Mitt
Romney for the presidential election
jenna jameson and clint eastwood this
week at Sarah Silverman coming out for
Obama as you can imagine she's doing it
very specifically though there is a guy
named Sheldon Adelson he is a casino
mogul he has vowed to give 100 million
dollars to Romney's campaign in order to
beat Obama so Sarah Silverman has gone
online and created a video addressing
Sheldon Adelson saying if he gives the
100 million dollars to Barack Obama she
will have lesbian sex with him she says
she won't sleep with him but she will
scissor him in a bikini bottom here's
here's the audio from the video here's
her she describes it better than I do if
you give that hundred million dollars to
Obama instead of Romney I will scissor
you wearing a bikini bottom through to
fruition that means until you come yeah
that means until you come she says all
the Republican billionaires are giving
money to Romney but how many of them are
getting scissored by a bikini bottom's
us with big naturals no word yet whether
he'll take up on her offer or not what
are naturals at its natural big natural
boobs oh okay well what do they have to
do with the scissoring nothing
right she's just throwing the men on
like hey bonus I think the whole body
comes I don't think she's gonna go no
around only the Weiner comes oh stop it
Kristen Stewart is wallowing in
self-pity since she stepped out on
Robert Pattinson [ __ ] rightfully she
should she cheated on him with that
other dude man it's heartbreaking to me
and I'm not even a twilight kid but I
find this heartbreak in the words of
Will Ferrell she's a [ __ ] I err she
[Music]
according to France is very depressed
refuses the shower hasn't washed her
hair in a week and simply laze around
eating ice cream yeah she's less
attractive this story came out describe
it a gun ralph refuses the shower yes
hasn't washed her hair in several days
simply laze around eating ice cream so
this could easily describe me you're
Kristen Stewart is what you're saying
[ __ ] she has a sinking feeling it's
totally over with the love of her life
Robert Pattinson well don't [ __ ]
touch other dudes wieners it's that
simple man we're very easy to please
just touch only our wieners actors Ellen
Page has it has a big problem on her
hand someone is sending her death
threats via her Twitter account one
tweet read I'm going to murder Ellen
Page she's dead there was a phone call
that came in to a film festival she was
attending promising to kill her
apparently it's all stems from the fact
that she went on a date with Alexander
Skarsgard to a king's game hey wait a
minute anything you'd like to tell us
Kevin that [ __ ] he's mine is this right
really the most recent tweets that Ellen
Page have you continued to date
Alexander Skarsgard I will kill you in
public in the next year wait man [ __ ]
Ellen Page from Juno yeah is dating
Alexander Skarsgard from True Blood yes
then I have a shot
I would like to see your Twitter account
because I think you're sending these
I'll kill you in public in the next year
being a club again in a restaurant or
when you're signing autographs oh I
would just say could you move it up the
whole year I don't want to wait around
for a year either it's tomorrow or it's
off that's what I would say I want to
live in fear for a year it's a bummer
man
a porn star Kim Kardashian's at it again
[Music]
kanye west revealed this week his new
single off his upcoming CD the new track
is called perfect [ __ ] he tweeted that
he wrote it about his girlfriend Kim
Kardashian here was the simple tweet I
wrote the song perfect [ __ ] about Kim
that romantic bastard Kim said I'm
honored I love it
I know he doesn't mean it in a negative
way when he says the word [ __ ] it's
true it is a term of endearment
sometimes sometimes I'll come home and
say what's for dinner [ __ ] my wife goes
oh you shall nuzzle me now say hey
where's the kid [ __ ] and then she'll
blow me because she so turned on can I
can I get a hand job [ __ ] never pans
out either this is what Kim thinks the
song means it's about how he met so many
other girls but could never find the
right one until he met me so it's
there's truth in that art she's the
perfect [ __ ] oh they asked 50 cent his
musical rival by the way what he thought
of the perfect [ __ ] being about Kim and
he said you know how it is
one man's trash is another man's
treasure that's kind of cute
rob kardashian the the only man in the
family
I'm talking to you Bruce Jenner he
tweeted that he was going to law school
he enrolled in law school it's gonna be
a lawyer he's made a decision in his
life the only problem is the school he
said he was going to usc's Gould School
of Law said Rob Kardashian's not coming
here
he hasn't even applied which is sad news
cuz I was hoping Rob would be as
honorable a lawyer as his father Robert
Kardashian was who of course got OJ
Simpson off so he did and then he got
him out of trouble legally too
if these gloves don't fit you must
acquit and that's drinking me off a new
reality show and the works on TLC or as
I like to call it the sideshow Channel
Abby and Brittany Hensel get their own
TV show those you don't know who the
hensel's are oh no they are conjoined
twins - mouths indeed sir you sick sick
[ __ ]
they have two heads
they are conjoined at the neck they have
two arms they originally had three but
they took one at Birth souvenir I guess
for the doctor they have two hearts four
lungs two stomachs no word on the vagina
Abby controls the right side of the body
Brittany controls the left side of the
body they just graduated from Bethel
University in Minnesota they just got
their degree and they're looking for a
post graduation job and that's what the
show is gonna be about I think they
found one reality show yeah I'm just
think if you go to college with
conjoined twins they're really throwing
off the bell curve because they got two
brains everything is easier for them
like a test they can ask each other what
do you get for number five I got 12 all
right they're cheating on each other any
moment there could be a quato type
situation they're making a movie about
the life of Liberace you guys know who
Liberace is big Liberace fan over there
I wish my brother George was here he was
a he was loading John before Elton John
he was very flamboyant he played piano
he liked a lot of man sex but people for
some reason people didn't know that well
he denied he was gay until he died right
yeah they're making a life story of
Liberace Michael Douglas is playing
Liberace Matt Damon is playing his
boyfriend I've seen a picture um they
look pretty good they say however they
think the spirit of Liberace is haunting
the set
apparently they felt drafts of cold damp
air and smelt strong whiffs of men's
cologne for no reason it smells like
semen so you know it's Liberace all some
but also caressed Michael Douglas's
shoulder and tightly secured lights have
been crashing from the ceiling for no
reason I can't explain the lights but
the massage shoulders could be John
Travolta that's true could be the ghost
of John Travolta so we're not even bad
and I'm massaging you Sheldon what where
this year on NBC John Travolta is gay
ghosts
[Laughter]
[Applause]
why don't you come to your senses get
ghosts we need your help we think the
old the old amusement park is haunted
we're the amusement park what
haunted so weird boo we'll be right back
with gay ghosts after these messages
could you blow me Lindsay Lohan had a
sleepover with Lady Gaga and then I woke
up in a cold sweat
apparently they slept together at the
Chateau Marmont does Lindsay have a home
or she just live at the Chateau Marmont
Hotel I I don't know yeah they had a
sleepover and now apparently Lindsay is
starring in Gaga's new video for her
upcoming album so once again Lindsay is
doing whatever it takes to get a job
that's the good news for Lindsay the bad
news is she had a freakout this week at
a Los Angeles nightclub whoa
Lindsay was at a nightclub
[Music]
clubs called Bootsy bellows which i
think is the name of the gay ghost this
year on NBC what Bootsy bellows the gay
ghost it's so weird
she went into Bootsy bellows and found
out that the private area for
celebrities was already taken by
francesca eastwood daughter of clint
eastwood and reality show star so
lindsay lost her [ __ ] starts screaming
i'm a star she's a nobody get her out of
here
people really [ __ ] talk like that
apparently they do witnesses say it was
like watching someone from like a 1980s
movie with someone's like out of control
on drugs or something [ __ ] like Joan
Collins and dynasty right thing if they
escorted her out security took her out
francesca eastwood had this to say I'm
not sure no she didn't say that too soon
I'm not sure what exactly sparked
Lindsay's outburst regardless I still
had an amazing birthday and Parent Trap
is still my favorite movie so that's
sweet well it's sweet but it's also like
really Parent Trap your favorite [ __ ]
movie I questioned your good taste in
music news Elton John is still battling
with Madonna Oh
gay people must be so torn over this
must be like must be like the the child
of a divorce when you watch Madonna and
Elton John fight it's been gone a long
time
2004 Elton John said anyone about
Madonna's torque anyone who lip syncs in
public on stage and charges 134 dollars
a ticket should be shot he might not
have been talking about her yeah then
when she was going to do the Super Bowl
show in January he said on Good Morning
America
I hope she lip-synchs good when I was
showing a TV this Sunday night he said
the following here's a little clip no
sorry she's a career's over I didn't
tell you that that too has been a
disaster and it couldn't happen to
bigger let me translate if you don't
speak Elton why is she such a nightmare
her careers over I can tell you that her
tour has been a disaster and they
couldn't happen to a bigger [ __ ]
can you feel the love tonight
[Music]
and from Elton John to Madge
Jesus man that's real caddy he added she
looks like a [ __ ] fairground stripper
[Laughter]
no I've been to lots of Fairgrounds I
saw John Travolta stripping in one
John's publicity team immediately went
into action and they denied Elton John
ever said those quotes they said they
were fabricated that's when they were
told that was aired on television John's
team said that conversation was off the
record off the record see first of all
you made it up and second of all it's
off the record
now listen me pal we're gonna square up
we're gonna throw Duke see they sent him
somebody from the 20s and [ __ ] that's
right and more music news Jaden Smith
dropped a new song this week oh thank
Christ this [ __ ] kid for those
unfamiliar with this Ralph periodically
gets very jealous of Hollywood children
no it's not that at all it's just that
they act like they're doing something
and if they didn't have famous rich
parents none of this would be happening
none of it he's got a new video this
week shows him and his skateboard
culture well you have to give him this
he does have his finger on the pulse of
America because I think this skateboard
thing is gonna take off I think it's
gonna be big it's a rap song that is
done to the Foster the People song
Pumped Up Kicks yeah that is the track
behind it and he raps lines like I'll
probably get some crap for this from my
parents and my sis and the people I'd be
acting with but it's cool I'm an actor
Tripp
he doesn't care man he doesn't care
about all those actors he makes all
those movies with what they think of him
he's gonna skateboard and rap I prefer
to hear the words coming from the
original artist Ralph well here's a
little here's a little piece of Pumped
Up Kicks like me as the name of the song
here is Jaden Smith rapping
you want to know what find me find a
place with a musket-ball scrape concrete
well my cheese behind me yeah we afraid
to Nunn design these wall piece and
Gandhi bone ain't never sleep you can
call me a semi yeah
if you couldn't make it out let me let
me give you those lyrics once again
everybody want kicks like me everybody
want chicks like me everybody want
flicks like me everybody trying to get
like me if you mean we'd all like to be
children of rich and famous parents who
give us everything then you're right we
would like that Jaden now maybes got
some skills let's read the rest I want
to know where to find me find a place
where the most skateboards scrape
concrete woman she's behind me yeah we
ain't afraid of nothing but zombies more
peace than Gandhi up all night never
sleep you can call me a zombie well he
does have a skill because he did run
zombies with [ __ ] zombie really
you're out with words that end with the
e sound I was gonna try to defend but I
really can no zombies two lines later
zombies right what could you go with
instead anything that ends with E
hominid Bambi that doesn't really rhyme
with zombie zombie
Romney yeah [ __ ] current and [ __ ]
people would have been like he's
political yeah he's deep yeah you can
call me Romney what why why would we do
that
time for movies that will suck
I wish you another Michael Bay they make
movies that make you say oh my god
that's [ __ ] what the [ __ ] they're
movies that will suck it every week I
pray I'm not this list you're not on the
list I look over and then I'm like oh I
don't make movies anymore so go ahead
man
this was threatened and now it's come to
pass
sony has announced they are indeed
making a big-budget live-action Alf
movie this is why I don't make movies
going to the Alf Alf of course the alien
life-form al F that's right
no problem they will e give me a kept
Gordon Shumway was his name on the show
that was funny in 1986 I wish we were
there the guy who did the voice of Alf
is gonna return oh thank Christ because
if it had been anyone else other than
Paul Fusco I was gonna boycott no
problem
what kind of cast do you think I think
oh I'm guessing Brian Reynolds will show
up someplace and Bill and Ted three has
been greenlit we're gonna get bill
instead three no you only think you want
to see that you don't want to see that
is it Keanu Reeves Keanu Reeves and Alex
winter are coming back to play
trust me you don't want to see it
because they're 50 ah so anyway I've got
enlarged prostate
ah or do i yes I wake up to pee at night
ah yes I do
sounds more like a [ __ ] confessional
than anything else but Bill and Ted at
50 what what what are they using as a
reboot like their kids are gonna be in
well but straight them just them the
script will be where they are in their
lives today they're taking blood
pressure medication that's what they're
doing it's also this movie will also
examine what happened to rock and roll
in the last 20 years well I'm glad it's
got a message thank God someone's gonna
ask the tough questions that's right
it's time for geek news Kevin and I look
at the geek news every week because
we're geeks
[Music]
Gillian Anderson split up with her her
longtime boyfriend of six years this
week I like this story kami - yeah I
don't believe it but I want it to be
true so I'm gonna say it out loud and I
wish I say it out loud maybe you know
this falling star will make it come true
to it she broke up with her boyfriend of
six years named mark griffiths the story
has it the rumor is that she is now in a
serious relationship with David Duchovny
how awesome would that be that is pretty
pretty damn weird but pretty Mulder and
Scully together finally Oh
cigarette smoking woman I believe the
truth is in they're gonna examine her
black hole gonna probe her don't [ __ ]
him to file the x5 I'm sorry I'm a big
fan they work together of course from
1993 to 2002 in the series they did the
movie version 2008 there had been rumors
of relationship but no one could ever
prove anything so now you know David's
broken up with Tea Leoni she's breaking
up with her boyfriend and people are
speculating at least that they're
together I choose to say yes I even
though like you know they are not the
characters they play it that just made
me really happy I read that I was like
oh I hope that's [ __ ] true the
Avengers - Joss Whedon has officially
signed on for the sequel I know it
seemed like that should be a foregone
conclusion but as as recently as
comic-con he said he didn't know if he
was gonna do it or not he's absolutely
doing it and he's also developing a TV
series for ABC that will take place
something they call The Avengers
universe I don't know what that means
maybe a shield series or something like
that but remember I mean I just watched
that again on the plane man that's a
great movie so there's one shot in that
movie right after I think it's right
maybe it was right before the Hulk punch
everybody knows like you know hope
the word goes flying but right before
that they do a shot somebody would argue
and say it's a tracking shot that's
really not the technical term for it but
there's a shot that kind of goes
throughout the city and hits every
avenger as they're doing a routine right
right right
it is spellbinding it is everything you
always wanted to see in a comic book
movie as a lifelong comic book fan
particularly in a team movie it was I
was sitting on the plane watching that I
could rewind
I literally rewound three times watch it
roll the [ __ ] tear dudes sitting next
to me is like you're kidding yeah and I
was like I cried at Batman too you know
just [ __ ] went back to this but it
was it's beautiful it's really well well
made I thought DC wants some of that
money - they're announced they're
Justice League movies in the works and
this week I'm sure you heard Kevin old
friend of yours was rumoured to be
directing this film Ben Affleck
apparently talked in talks to direct the
Justice League listen you can say what
you want about him as an actor but he's
a damn good director yeah man Gone Baby
Gone is a wonderful movie to town and
this new movie that they did the
trailers up for Argo looks fantastic it
looks like he's gonna win a bunch of
awards as well now some people are
saying he's just broke recently but ever
all week on Twitter people what do you
think about this breaking news I was
like I remember when I heard about it
for months ago I thought for a second
like that'd be fun but I doubt he'll do
it he doesn't need to do it you know
what I'm saying like he's got looks like
he's got an awards moving his pocket
he's kind of carving out a niche that's
a little more than the Sydney [ __ ]
slash Sidney Lumet so I don't know that
he necessarily needs to make justice
what if he wants to play one of the
heroes though because I think he'd make
a great Wonder Woman
I'll go with me on that cuz I think he
I've said many times he's a wonderful
actor and I feel he could play anything
including the shark and a jaws remake so
if I had my way I'd let you just do a
Justice League movie and Ben could play
every part including [ __ ] Wonder
Woman happy awesome
Marvel is in talks with Fox because they
had to make a deal in order to keep
daredevil the rights for that movie over
there at Fox they have to start making a
movie by October 10th or else the rights
for daredevil go back to Marvel so Fox
went to them and said look we want to
keep it what do you want let's make a
deal and marble said give us Galactus
and Silver Surfer from the Fantastic
Four rights that you have and we'll give
you an extended period of time you can
make your daredevil movie so apparently
that's what's gonna happen there you
have that made that deal so they're
keeping daredevil and they're giving
back Galactus and Silver Surfer now I
think they can also use Galactus and
Silver Surfer and other projects if they
want with the Fantastic Four but I don't
have exclusive rights on them yeah they
can add that because Fox is talking
about rebooting the Fantastic Four as
well they want to do new Fantastic Four
movies they'd be silly not to who are
they talking about rebooting daredevil
with is a joe carnahan yes who did a
team and the gray I guess for his big
movies right if they do reboot the
Fantastic Four here's who I want to play
the Human Torch I pride myself on being
a geek I also pride myself in knowing
some trivia and [ __ ] when I found out
this story this week my [ __ ] head
exploded because I had no idea this
existed but there was a radio play of
the Fantastic Four in the early 1970s it
was a radio play with parently it was
like we did with the Hollywood babble-on
comic-book theater that they would take
the comic books and they would turn them
into radio plays they were actually
broadcast in the mid early 70s only 10
episodes existed this week people
started talking about and I was like why
didn't someone [ __ ] telling me this
before the role of the Human Torch
Johnny Storm was played by Bill Murray
in that play Bill Murray was the Human
Torch in the radio play
please tell me havoc I brought some
audio of the radio play I'm not you
won't listen to this you'll you'll say
yeah oh yeah it's him it's it's this is
the first episode of this 10 episode
series this radio play this is the
origin of the Fantastic Four this is
after they've been bombarded by cosmic
rays and Johnny Storm has seen them all
change into these monsters and then he
realizes he can burst into flames this
is Bill Murray playing the Human Torch I
don't know what happened there but they
seemed saying you're all monsters it's
as if he's doing the closing monologue
from Scrooged as the Human Torch and if
you do it every day you're learning to
like it and you'll want it every day I'm
on fire sue it sounds more like stripes
to me where it's like don't go all the
plants will die hey we can find it
online you can check that out we end
every show with the same musical
question each and every week the
question Kevin asked so many many moons
ago about the size of certain actors
certain part of his body how big is Liam
Neeson's [ __ ]
we can't help but wonder how big it's
easy oh nice it's nice and [ __ ] calm is
where to go for all your facts about
Liam Neeson's [ __ ] so I'll make sure you
show up there and read all the the facts
these are just a couple of them Liam
Neeson's [ __ ] is so big before he has
sex with a woman his [ __ ] will spring
from his pants and sing a number from
Little Shop of Horrors Liam Neeson's
[ __ ] is so big the Justice League has
used it as a headquarters meanwhile in
the [ __ ] of justice Liam Neeson's [ __ ]
is so big he made a sex type sex tape
entitled invasion for flesh and blood
that's a callback from last week Liam
Neeson's [ __ ] is so big Ralph Garman is
trying to get Adam West a star on it and
I think he deserves it Liam Neeson's
[ __ ] is so big that Peter Jackson was
going to make two movies about it and
decide to make it 3 Liam Neeson's [ __ ]
is so big that Sinead O'Connor drew a
blank when trying to think of something
to compare it to yeah that's all that's
what we call a homer you'll be driving
home going really early ninety's joke
man that's amazing
Liam Neeson's [ __ ] is so big
it wears a cape doesn't mean anything
but just made me laugh I just you Liam
Neeson's [ __ ] is so big if you drop a
rubik's cube down his pants it will be
solved by the time it falls out the leg
Liam Neeson's [ __ ] is so big that when
Liam was a baby it started teething
before he did okay wait I haven't been
paying attention hold on Liam Neeson's
[ __ ] wait a minute that's calm so the
natural condition of [ __ ] is in the
mouth
according to sign language wait Liam
Neeson there's not short for Liam Neeson
got to come up with something shorter
than that do this cuz that's Liam Neeson
going listen to me you're going to be
taken alright so now let's see Liam
Neeson's [ __ ] with a new word give it up
for the sign language guy sign language
guy
he has a very unique set of skills have
you seen the [ __ ] trailer for take it
- it's like a parody it's it does seem
like a YouTube clip listen your mother's
going to be taken just like you were
last time remember
remember when you were taken and look
what and you might get taken - and and
and I might be taken as well take it -
everybody gets [ __ ] tanked this is
just a picture of him holding on to his
[ __ ] dick sooner or later everyone
gets taken away aneesa's [ __ ] is so big
he's had to hire a crew to clean the
graffiti off of it and I think that's a
shame kids today with their tagging take
a Central Park Rock Liam Neeson's [ __ ]
is so big when they first met Neil
Armstrong sunk a flag into it one small
[ __ ] for mankind
and lastly Liam Neeson's [ __ ] is so big
that I would walk 500 miles and I would
walk 500 more just to be the man who
walked a thousand miles to fall down at
Liam's balls
[Applause]
San Juan Capistrano go cows did you have
a great time tonight thank you so much
for coming out and spending your evening
with us we were truly appreciated and in
his reference to the immortal Carlo
Rambaldi
we'll be back did he ever say that was
the terminator you're my bad do it be
back tonight everybody that's Hollywood
babble-on for this week man I'm Kevin
Smith I'm Ralph Garman
I believe [ __ ] off San Juan Capistrano
good night ladies and gentlemen give it
up for Kevin Smith and the world Garmin
Hollywood babble-on live at the
coach-house
[Music]
you